stranger things had trained rats for the
show so
why were they fired in this video we'll
be looking behind the scenes at all the
cgi creations from the show
what did it look like when millie bobby
brown was battling the mind flayer
how about the special software that made
the rats bubble
let's take a look
millie bobby brown puts up a pretty
amazing fight against the mind flayer
but on the set she definitely had the
upper hand since these
wild long and slimy tentacles weren't
actually there and on the attack
brown's performance combined with the
cgi creatures make this scene totally
believable
of course we can't forget this special
monster attack
it's honestly a terrifying moment but
taking a peek behind the scenes we see
the monster wasn't the slimy mess that
we see
but a lump of black material with some
tracking spots on it that gets thrown
off and away
well that's nice we can't talk about the
vfx of the netflix hit without
acknowledging one of the most
incredible cgi feats of all we're
talking about
the mind flayer with the effects brought
to life this creature stands to be one
of the most terrifying there is
but behind the scenes it's a totally
different picture as we can see here
with this giant beach ball at the end of
a stick waving around throughout the set
of a mall
this blue screen in the middle of the
forest also helped in playing the role
of the mind flayer
check out how much of the shot is
actually entirely cgi created
as for when dakor montgomery faces off
with the monsters
instead of the giant creature coming at
him from above we can see that his enemy
is actually
angled up from below and less slimy and
well more like a long silver pole with a
big black handle at the end
at the other end of the pole was a
stuntman just hidden off screen
all this time we've been building it
while the majority of this monster was
created with cgi
behind the scenes things looked less
terrifying and a bit
well uh absurd check out this stunt guy
dressed in red with
yes that's a mirrored helmet his running
around
flailing arms and screaming looks
ridiculous as is here but
when the effects are all added in we see
just how effective the simulation is for
creating the tom bruce monster
check him out as he manages to creepily
crawl over natalya dyer
his creature-like movements are perfect
for emanating the monster that would
join via cgi
part of the reason for having this
physical person enact the monster was to
help the actor's performances
while it looks a bit silly it was
clearly super effective and helped the
whole team to bring their a-game
oh and as for the mirror helmet it
wasn't just used because of how cool it
looks
practically it was used to capture the
light reflecting and how it would hit
the creature
a special detail that really helped make
the cgi look real
when the signature neon lights of the
star court mall aren't up the building
doesn't look as wonderful
and the fact is it's entirely created by
cgi anyway
we can see in the mapping here that
they're making sure to take care of
every single detail
these cgi cars spread throughout the
parking lot the detailed work on the
roof
and of course the recognizable bright
front entrance
as for the inside of the mall well it's
pretty real but
fortunately the mind flayer didn't do
nearly as much damage as we see in the
final cut
we can see in this behind the scene shot
that the destruction of the mind flayer
is done mindfully with some practical
bits adjusted here and there
the set is definitely a mess when the
monster is finally defeated
there are some obvious worn and damaged
looking remnants we can see here
combine this set with these incredible
special effects and the result
really is amazing
there were some very messy interactions
between the humans and the monsters
remember all those people that were
flayed each one of them had practical
makeup done but when the monster took
over
cgi was key remember the tentacles
latched directly on these faces
it's a terrifying image but behind the
scenes there was a lot of playing
pretend and the actors
definitely did a stellar job at acting
as if life were being taken from them
you don't have to do this while there
were loads of incredible cgi creations
throughout the stranger things series
the rats of season 3 were epic first of
all
just look at the sheer number of them
scurrying about
they look freakishly real and in fact at
one time
they were the team actually had rats
trained and prepared but
they turned out to not be at the same
level as the rest of the performers
so these cgi rodents were brought to
life just when we think we've seen them
all
somehow more rats always seem to appear
out of nowhere
the amount of detail really adds to how
convincing these scenes look
if we check it out closely we can see
literally every strand of hair
whisker and of course those signature
creepy black beady eyes
then of course are the rats that go
through uh well let's just say a bit of
a tougher time
more on those cgi rodents later
why just have regular rats when you can
also have melting and exploding rats
okay maybe we haven't thought that
ourselves but the stranger things team
definitely did
remember these melting creatures in miss
driscoll's basement
let's just say we preferred them when
they were the regular creepy rats
how did they make these strange and
literally bubbly effects
a special software called houdini was
responsible for those effects used for
the textures
the jam-like substance is super creepy
to begin with
and then it moves the effects team put
great detail into simulating a mixture
of various items and of course
coated it off with some slime for good
measure
did you happen to notice the slick black
tail amongst the slime blob
it's that kind of extra touch that
really made these creatures perfect for
the world of stranger things
the effects team made sure to get the
approval of the kids at the show too
all of whom thought their creation was
horrifying
that's when they knew it was a winner
remember this dark and stormy beach it
was much more pleasant when they were
actually shooting
they added these incredible huge rolling
clouds further highlighted by the reds
blues and purples bursting through with
light creating an extremely intimidating
scene
how about this intense fight it looks
like it's right in the middle of this
brutal and blustering storm but in
reality
the whole thing wasn't even taking place
on the beach like it was earlier in the
scene
this whole sequence looks so different
and way less intense in the green screen
studio but the actors do an amazing job
with their performances to make the
whole scene believable
the added vfx and cgi just bring it to
that stellar stranger things level
like this was one of the duffer brothers
favorite vfx used in the third season of
stranger things
inside the russian lab our minds are
totally blown when we see the high-tech
machinery going the giant spinning
turbine-like object alone has
excellent effects like the speed of the
spinning lighting within and the way the
mechanism moves as a whole
even some characters like these workers
we see are entirely computer generated
though there was an actual structure
that sat in the place of the fantastical
machine
see this long frame that holds the
general shape of the turbine
the team even added these large silver
balls to reflect the lights
realistically so the effects team had
that to work with while adding all the
cgi we see in the final product
the snow in this exterior shot is both
gorgeous and extensive
we totally believe it could be a real
place until we see the cgi magic behind
the creation showing us that it is just
that
a totally cgi creation in order to bring
the scene to life realistically
the team incorporated things like
thousands of snowflakes floating in the
air
as well as using wind simulation so the
blustering landscape looks real
looking closely we can appreciate all
the architectural details added
all of this really completes the
incredible computer generated images
who do you work for the cgi of stranger
things has continued to improve
throughout the seasons and we
have no doubt that the fourth season
will do the same
which effect do you think was the
hardest to create
you